city of London at Royal Holloway Martin
has worked a lot on the concrete
hardness of lwe against various attacks
like lattice reduction attacks pkew and
so on
he's also caught he's also authored the
most used script to estimate the
hardness of lwe life instances and he's
also co-authored the best SVP
implementation with the Leo Tioga also
known as just a classic he's worked on
problem bases symmetric key crypto and
especially on symmetric key crypto for
fhe so let's welcome back thank you very
much so
the title I was giving was algorithms
for laughes problems in practice and
then the first question is what do you
mean by practice right do we mean
cryptographic parameters are those
practice or do we mean practice as and
we actually run these algorithms I will
focus on cryptographic parameter sizes
that's my practice as we will probably
never run these instances but let's see
what the workshop brings huh okay so as
a way of motivating this talk here is a
bunch of estimates for the difficulty of
breaking candidates that were submitted
to the NIST post quantum process time
yours going to talk about this process a
bit later what matters here is not so
much the different columns how these
schemes compare to each other because
it's also different parameter sets and
so on
what matters is a different rules and so
what we have is like this is a selection
of five of these assumptions and I think
in this paper where I took this from BLX
17 or something we just what do all the
designers think how long does it take to
actually solve lattice problems and then
we took those and applied them to all
the schemes to just see kind of like
what this the diversity of opinions on
how long this takes and clearly we have
estimates that differ quite a bit right
so either it takes something like to 180
operations to break hiber or through the
450 right it's really far apart and so
maybe we should kind of look into that a
bit more closely
okay what this is essentially an
argument about is about the difficulty
of solving this problem right you've
seen this before the learning with
errors problem I give you a matrix a and
the vector C and then your job as the
attacker is to find s where s is
multiplied by a but then we put to the
result a little bit with a small error E
and this has both a search version which
I've given on the slide and the decision
which we decide on whether C is formed
like this or C is uniformly random you
can also think about the matrix entry
problem where you have two small
matrices one of them is invertible you
multiply the inverse of one with the
other one you get some matrix H out and
then your job is to find a small
multiple of F og but in this talk I will
focus on lwe
with some modifications the techniques
translate right but I will focus on a
little bit here okay
so let's do the so called primal
approach let's solve other way e
directly so what we have is C minus a
times s is congruent to e mod Q so let's
write this down over the integers all
that means is that we have to explicitly
take care of the model reductions so we
add or subtract a bunch of multiples of
Q so we can write that a matrix form or
or we can write this in one big matrix
right so this matrix B down here if I
multiply from the right with this vector
where the star represents the molar
reductions I have my s and then I have a
1 then what I get out is the vector es +
1 and by construction E and s and also
the integer 1 small so there is an
integer linear combination of the
columns of this matrix that gives me
something very small so there is these
are indeed unusually small we wouldn't
expect something this small if this
matrix B was constructed randomly so
what we have here is a unique shortest
vector problem but so the computational
problem then becomes you give them a
basis like this and your job is to find
one of these unique shortest vectors or
up to sines we may assume for now that
this is unique and there's a decision
variant of this where simply your job as
an attacker is to decide on whether such
a you are unusually short vector exists
right in the lattice generated by the
spaces in nth row you have n of these
unusually short things in l.o.v.e of 1
ok so how we go about this well we want
to find something short and a lattice so
we use lattice reduction most of the
introductory material and last reduction
I don't have to repeat you've already
seen excellent talks on that I'm just
going to recall a few notions that we're
going to make use of in particular we're
going to make use of the volume of a
lattice which is the volume of its
fundamental parallelepiped
and we expect by the Ghazni eristic that
the shortest vector in a random lattice
will be roughly square root D normal by
some constant times the volume of the
lattice taken to the 1 over D throat
sorry the default and so what we mean by
unusually short is there is a short
vector in this lattice that is much
shorter than this bound what we would
expect for random lattice
all right in order to talk about last
reduction algorithms we will make use of
camp Smith vectors also of course you've
seen those in the context of lattice
reduction before and what this means is
we're taking out the contributions of
the previous vectors when we talk about
some particular vector right so here the
two-dimensional example b1 and I'm
projecting the orthogonal to B naught
that means I'm taking out the
contribution of B naught from b1 to
arrive at P 1 star and so on and I keep
on going and then I get the
accomplishment vectors the reason why
we're doing this is because we like to
draw pictures of our lattices and so
this is a picture that we like to draw
so we take those car MIT vectors then we
take their norms and then we plot them
all right
so on the left hand side is the first
vector B not the norm of B naught star
which is the norm of B naught and on the
right is in this example of 120
dimensional lattice is the norm of the
last one right projected along with
everything and so and this is what you
would expect as the input of your
lattice problem because we have cuarón
lattices so we have a bunch of Q's and
then we project orthogonal and then what
we are left with at the end is a bunch
of ones so in Lock space they become a
bunch of zeros and then these are lock
use all right and so so that is in a way
our input instance how it looks like in
this visualization of lattices so what
do we do we want to do lattice reduction
the first thing that we always do is run
lll right so let's run ll on this thing
and then what we end up with is
something like this all right so all
I've done is I talked in the previous
basis I've run a little reduction on
that and I giving you the same plot and
as you can see we now get something
that's roughly aligned and indeed the
geometric series assumption states that
that's how like whatever lattice
reduction algorithm you run and I'm you
know being quite hand baby here you
expect a line like this and your
algorithm gets better or as your
algorithm gets better has stronger
reduction it becomes flatter and flatter
right so really kind of like all I'm
going to talk about it's like draw
pictures like this and I want the line
to be flat and flat
that's all like I'm struggling with the
simple task of writing a parallel line
like I can't even do that and we invest
computational resources to just do that
okay so that is our assumption how these
things look like okay so strong lattice
reduction what I mean by that in the
context of this talk I mostly mean the
big heads that algorithm which you have
seen in newest talk already and just to
give you a brief refresher on how this
algorithm proceeds so it calls an SVP
Oracle in some smaller dimension
repeatedly in order to make local
improvements to the
basis it combines them in order to have
a basis that is nice globally so in this
particular instance I have my block size
equals five so I'm going to call the SVP
Oracle in dimension five I'm going to
ask it the Oracle would you be so kind
and give me a shortest vector in
dimension in this small basis after
mention five and the Oracle being a nice
Oracle is happy to oblige I'm going to
insert it I'm going to move on and I'm
not actually going to move on to the
vectors B 1 to B 5 but I'm going to move
on to the vectors B 1 to B 5 projected
orthogonal e2 the first vector and then
I'm going to ask the same question to my
Oracle would you be so kind to give me a
short vector or the shortest vector and
the Oracle still being nice it obliges I
inserted and so on and I keep on going
like this until I hit the end and then I
start at the beginning and I keep on
doing this until there's no more
improvement to be made until the Oracle
essentially returns the answer that I
already know the thing that is the first
vector in my local basis all right so
that's the whole algorithm and here's a
high-level view of this we want to run
some lll on our blocks to make sure we
have some guarantees and things are not
too bad but then all we're doing is to
find short vectors in local blocks and
we insert them and we keep on going
until there's no more improvement to be
made okay if you do that then you you
get some guarantees out of these
algorithms how short do you get in
particular the provable guarantees
somewhat of this form so on the left
hand side the because that algorithm so
what you end up with is something
depends on this quantity gamma beta to
the one over essentially beta minus one
and then you take that to the dimension
essentially and then we expressing this
as a function of the volume so that is
on the ruler might factor and sorry the
HAR might factor and then we can also
express the guarantees that we get as
like how much larger than the shortest
vector that's actually in the
lattice to beget right and so there's a
square of this how much constant
asymptotically best I think that is
still the state of the art would be
slight reduction which gives you a
slightly better guarantees and how might
regime but in particular I want to
stress you get this D minus beta and the
exponent for slide reduction when you
get the D minus one in the exponent for
big hazard right but these are the kind
of the guarantees what you can prove yes
please it's because the statements were
like I lifted the theorem statements
from the respective works and I think
there's a I think I absorb that into the
plus one here because it's actually
slightly smaller than the plus one so
but yeah I don't think this is a
fundamental difference okay so and then
so what matters so this this this
constant here this gamma beta to the one
over beta much depends on the block size
so as you if you increase the block size
you get a better reduced basis but also
the cost of the algorithm will improve
and so these are the be known how much
constants that they're only known up to
dimension twenty four but we know a
gamma beta itself is bounded by beta
itself okay so so this is kind of some
guarantees so let's talk about what
would expect on average and on average
will be essentially expect you take your
guarantees you replace the hamid
constant which tells you this is the
longest thing you can possibly get with
the thing that we expect well what do we
expect we expect the thing predicted by
the Ghazni eristic so we effectively
plug that in alright so that's how we
get a rough estimate for well what do we
actually expect as the output quality of
the algis right and I didn't really
modify the exponents or anything is just
replaced the gamma beta to the one over
beta by Delta beta which is effectively
the gamma beta here being replaced by
the Ghazni restive
the thing that we would expect it
doesn't quite hold for small block sizes
but for block size larger than 50 this
Delta beta kind of matches that
expression quite well and so if we have
this Delta beter than another geometric
series assumption what we have is the
slope of this line I told you the slope
gets flatter and flatter depends on this
Delta beta so here's some particular
kind of how this Delta beta develops as
you increase beta but the key point is
those Delta beaters they're much smaller
than those expressions right so we
expect something much better than what
the guarantees tell you okay so we said
in practice so let's look at how this
looks like so here's a a particular
instance of some random QA lattice and
running because at 60 in the major at 80
I'm starting off with a similar thing as
I showed you before some lll basis right
and so what the geometric series
assumption tells me is after I finished
one in this algorithm I should get
something that is really close to this
black line right so that's what I'm
expecting to see if I keep on running
this and I told you I'll keep repeating
this process of going through my basis
from front to back until no more changes
are made and so you can see if I run
this process one I get slightly better
and now I keep on going until I think I
stop at 206 I get something that's
fairly close to the spheres a line oh no
seven how far did I go oh yeah seven I
don't know why I did that
and and then so I get something that's
quite close to this G is a line but you
can see it's not quite here right so
there's a this doesn't seem to be quite
alone in the end and indeed at the end
the G is a cannot possibly hope because
you have an H cos H shape here but this
is something that I'm going to brush
another carpet for the rest of the talk
right but you can see like some roughly
these predictions you know they seem to
kind of like this somewhat correspond to
what you
will you observe at least in this
particular example okay if you want to
try this at home kits you can so here's
the code I ran to produce this and so
all of this is the code I'm running so
far as implementing the FPL library has
a friendly Python interface it is comes
with every copy of sage you can even run
it in your browser you don't need to
install anything there's really no
reason why you wouldn't just you know
run a few laps reductions kind of in
your spare time because it's so easy and
certainly the people who wrote all this
code many of them are here today would
certainly appreciate more people
actually using it to play with these
algorithms cool okay so now let me give
you a very because all I've done so far
is talk about lattice reduction Wyden
seems like essentially draw a line and
it approaches this line seems to be okay
but what we want to do is we want to
solve find this unusually short vector
right so that's the thing that we are
after finding this a newly short vector
so the question is how how strong does
my lattice would actually need to be in
order to find this unusually short
vector and so I'm going to give you a
very hand wavy and go just going to
replace bounds by expectations like it's
nothing
argument to give you like a rough idea
what you expect and I'm going to relate
that to like a prediction that we have
experimentally verified that seems to
match this so one way of how you could
reason about this is to say okay these
two different bounds for the performance
of my algorithm in terms of quality how
much longer is it then the Ghazni
eristic and how much longer is it than
the shortest vector so you could say if
somehow the lengths that I'm that this
algorithm gives me like if the bound for
the much longer than the shortest vector
is smaller than the thing then the
Gaggia heuristic would predict me
predict to me then you know I have at
least learned that this basis doesn't
seem to behave like a random basis all
right so because I get something that is
shorter
than what I would expect for a random
lattice so I could say well if the the
second if the M you see if the left hand
side is smaller than the right hand side
then you know I have maybe observed
something that isn't just random about
my basis and I have effectively solved
decision lwe right if I can observe this
so I'm just rearranging so that gives me
a condition for how much shorter my
shortest vector should be then
essentially the end D througt of my
lattice in order to succeed so this is
using the guarantees for B cassette or
the expectations plug into the
guarantees of B care set and I can do
the same thing for slide reduction right
and if I do this for slide with action
actually get something that is slightly
better right so then I can afford to
have a bit longer shortest vector that
it would still find in a given block
size because I have this two beta factor
here as opposed to just the minus D
there I'm not having it there okay
now let's compare this with the I don't
know for some reason we started calling
the 2016 estimate because there was also
a 2008 estimate that I'm not going to
mention here and this is due to Leo and
what he was what they were predicting in
the a New Hope paper is essentially to
say well take the the norm of the
expected norm of your shortest vector
and then there's an additional factor
here and then you win if that is smaller
by a delta peter to the two beta minus t
minus one right times the d fruit of the
lattice portland so if you compare and
then i want to stress that this is a
prediction about peak has that there's
not a prediction about slight reduction
all right so the prediction about
because that is actually you get the
same exponent as you get inspired
reduction in fact you can do slightly
better right there's this kind of
slightly kind of smaller correction
factor so how does this argument work
and now it will pay off that we painted
these pictures so the idea is let's
assume I've done my lapse reduction and
so far I have not uncovered anything
unusual about my basis but it behaves
like a random basis so I'm going to
assume the GS a Holtz okay so my basis
roughly corresponds to this black line
and now I'm going to look at the
projection of my my shortest vector with
respect to you know nothing the first
vector and so the first eye vectors why
I'm just protecting my shortest vector
orthogonal to the first basis vectors
and so if I if I if I look at the what I
would expect for the norm of like you
know protecting an essentially random
vector orthogonal to an increasing
dimensional space then then I get this
dotted line and now I'm looking at the
last full block that because that is
going to consider
that's the block that starts at in this
D minus beta right and in this block I'm
running an SVP Oracle so if that if that
projection is shorter than the vector
that the GSA predicts then the SVP
Oracle has to return it to me
it is in that basis but it is shorter
than what the GSA would predict so what
the supr Q will do is like Martin you
asked me for the shortest vector in this
block here it is and it's actually the
projection of my unusually short vector
with respect to the first II minus beta
basis vectors so I will insert it here
and then the next time I can effectively
do the same thing kind of but moving a
beta steps to the to the left but you
can also say simply run an argument
saying I if that happens if I find some
that's unusually short here I can use
that to decide that I have something
that doesn't live up to my expectation
of a random matters thus I have soft
decision lwe right so that's where where
this argument comes from and note that
this is an argument that is completely
about because that it's not about
so okay in the New Hope paper this
argument was presented and so the
question is like you know what about
experimental evidence can it actually
behave like that and so here is our
attempt at verifying this so and indeed
the outcome of our work was like it
seems to behave like that all right so
we ran I think like 10,000 core hours
and now Nadia chequered says like 10,000
course that's nothing but for us it was
a lot and so just ran many lattice
productions and effectively what we have
is indeed when this condition holds then
then lattice reduction will find the
unusually short aspect all right so it
seems we have a fairly good handle on
what block size bethe do we need in
order to actually find this unusually
short vector and thus break early so all
that's left to do is to argue about how
long does it you know the because that
algorithm repeatedly calls this SVP
Oracle and small dimensions so how how
expensive is that right so solving STP
is the problem that we're left with and
this is really like this disagreement
isn't about kind of like that argument
like when when does usvp succeed i
didn't check all the submissions but
this is not the the argument the
argument is really one about how long
does it take to solve SVP in dimension
beta and there's two classes of
algorithms that are being considered one
a saving we already heard about it has
exponential time but also exponential
memory and then there's immigration
which is effectively an exhaustive
search which has time Batala peter and
the exponent but only polynomial memory
right and the red ones are saving
estimates and the blue one are
enumeration estimates so let's talk
about this line with the one over to e
so what this does is it takes a table
from yami-chan thesis and plots
you know that's curve fitting that's how
this estimate was established so they
have numbers for up to dimension 250 on
the expected cost of solving SCP using
enumeration and then someone you know
did curve fitting two to fit a times B
log beta minus B plus C and then this is
the numbers that came out so a problem
with this data set is is just the table
right there's no source code to verify
it to kind of or to extend it right so
we want to know is this an an accurate
estimate but but in FPL these days we
actually have all the ingredients to do
this to extend this simulations so
that's what I did and as you can see so
it's the the same curve fit but now I've
extended this to dimension 500 which for
enumeration should cover you for sick
relevant securities and then seems to
match very well okay you could still say
Martin these are simulations who knows
how actual code behaves I'm glad you
asked so this is how actual code behaves
so the blue one is the curve that I've
just shown you on the previous slide the
green one is the actual running time
where I'm translating from seconds to
visit it notes using some standard kind
of estimates from the literature and
then you can also ask FPL how many notes
did you actually visit and as you can
see as you increase the dimensions those
three curves they seem to agree quite
closely so it seems this if you're
asking yourself how long this
illumination take then that seems to be
like for currently implemented publicly
available algorithms seems to be a
fairly good fit
and interesting or you can eat like you
can interpret these kind of estimates in
light of actually an argument about
worst-case complexity because the the
reason why I interpreted whatever
numerical value the curve fitting output
as 1 over 2 e is because that's actually
what we would expect so we would expect
from some work by Daniel that the
leading constant is indeed 1 over 2 e
and it seems our practical
implementations have that complexity so
you on the other hand if you make an
assumption which is essentially either
do you say then you expect that lattice
reduction has a leading constant of 1 of
8 so which is a bit smaller than 1 over
2 e right and so this is also this is a
quote from the same work by W and I need
firm conjecture this is the best you can
do so in in the LLL book he said like
you know they have some he gave some
heuristic arguments to say 1 over 8 like
that seems to be the limit for
enumeration algorithms so let me spell
out this difference for you a little bit
if you go back so now I've replaced the
G's a by the outputs of a peak has that
simulator and as I mentioned you don't
quite have the GSA at the end you get an
edge case that would use tape and then
you get the line here and what this
again very hand waving Li what this
boils down to it's an argument about we
can do in a way enumeration in 1 over 8
here we can only do enumeration in 1
over 2 e here there's roughly kind of
what what this is an argument about so
then that doesn't sound so bad
right because we could still kind of do
a lot of enumeration over here in 1 over
8 so that's great but the reason why we
can't have nice things is that a we the
way we get practical performance is by
randomizing our bases all the time which
means we
destroying this noise do you say shape
but and then in order to kind of fix
that up we run local pre-processing
which then essentially put something
like this in that green block over there
so that means we can't have this really
nice shape and the other thing is in the
senpai model as I up something in the
first block then I start kind of
affecting the quality of the next block
negatively right so there will be two
fundamental obstacles to to getting one
over eight however it seems you can
actually achieve something in the
ballpark of one over eight but simply
saying like how about I move all that
crap to the right right my problem is
that I do pre-processing which puts an
edge case edge shape here how about I do
pre-processing and a larger dimension
and I move that edge cares that shape to
the part that I'm not going to enumerate
over putting a nice line at the
beginning of my block all right
then it would be a strategy that you
could try since you already have
simulators we might as well simulate
that and if you believe the simulator
then indeed it seems you can achieve one
over it inside because it not for SVP
yes please okay we mean by the line but
what's the algorithm actually doing this
pushing you run pre-processing and I
mention say to beta and then it puts a
line and an edge cares that shape and
then you numerate over the first part
and there's a there's a bunch of stuff
well Akili can't do this at the very end
of this block right at the very last
block because there's nothing I can push
it into does it affect the quality so
I'm giving you a very hand wavy argument
here this is work in progress but at
least in terms of like running time it
seems you can achieve something close to
one over yes
with the one over to the second term is
- bit too extreme Cooney yeah yeah yeah
is it confirmed by your simulation or I
need to look at the plots so this is
definitely extreme pooling like the top
one the bottom one I would assume the
probability also drops exponentially but
I didn't actually I never plot their
quantity but I can't answer the question
right now but I have the data on this
machine to answer it
so give me ten minutes after the talk
okay so that's one nice and well so we
can maybe achieve one over eight cool
but the problem is Civic outperforms
enumeration asymptotically alright so
maybe maybe all of this isn't that
important if the crossover point is low
enough to be practical or to at least be
for cryptographic parameters okay
so you've seen much nicer saving
pictures in in noir stock but let me
give you my attempt at drawing saving
pictures
so why saving works by sampling many
vectors from our lattice that are kind
of long and then essentially checking if
I take the difference of two of them
maybe I get something short right so I
look at these two and turns out if I
reduce them then I get something shorter
you keep on doing that you take that as
the input for the next round and so on
all right so that's the serving I would
so the purpose what I'm going to talk
about next let's talk about a trick that
we use in implementations called pop
count so what I could do is I could try
to instead of doing pairwise comparison
with everything in my space how about I
only do comparison with things we expect
that this comparison might yield
something that actually reduced
something shorter
so what I could do is I could draw a
line through my space and I'm going to
say like okay only if the things end up
on the same side of the line that I'm
going to consider them if they don't
that I don't even consider that so I
could in a way use this as a 1-bit
locality-sensitive hashing function
right it's a 1/1 bit hash of these
vectors those are say 1 and those are
says you alright and then this way I can
maybe just compare these hashes as
opposed to comparing the full vectors
and indeed we can concatenate several of
them and then we get n bit locality
sense of hash functions and then in
order to have a first check of weather
is useful to compare two vectors is we
XOR them and we look at the Hamming
weight so we're checking on how many of
these hash functions do these vectors
agree if they agree on many of these
hash functions or under many of these
hash functions then they might they
might be in a similar direction so it's
useful to subtract them if not then
maybe it not and so this is what we call
pop kontrick it has a hospital names I'm
sure okay and then the last thing just
Bri if you want to mention is it's the
idea of bucketing what I can do is like
ignore that the implementation trick for
now I could pick I could pick
essentially a part of space and then I
go into check I'm only going to compare
two vectors if they form it to that part
of space right and then there would be
some bucketing and then I don't have to
compare everything with everything okay
so the cost if effectively is the simple
algorithm that I described at the
beginning where you do pairwise
comparison of everything with everything
which is why it's a quadratic in the
size of the database of vectors that you
consider then bgj is the idea to put
those put those vectors into buckets and
then only comparing things inside
buckets and BD GL is a way of deciding
which bucket to consider
using coats so because if I just put
them into random buckets then I need to
check every single bucket to see if my
thing belongs in there and we can do
slightly faster and then this is what
the BG L served us and so and then this
is this this constant that we saw in
this cost estimate right so that's where
it comes from the leading constant of
this house so what we did with Jessica
and then you can meet Jessica she's here
but back there's another Jessica which
is a library for doing civic it's a
Python C++ library to experiment with
saving algorithms so you can use them
inside outside because that and so key
tricks that we use in this library is so
I talked about because that as this in
this Oracle view where you have your
basis you ask an Oracle please give me
the shortest vector and then it will
turn you a vector you insert and you
carry on and we're not taking that view
but instead we take we're making use of
the fact I have an exponential list of
pretty good vectors right because that's
what a sip outputs and a sip
internally has this shrinking database
like shrinking enorm database of our
vectors in your lattice and then how
about we keep making use of that
database instead of throwing it away in
each step when we kind of ask the Oracle
when we implemented server safe
algorithms but we did not implement B
DGL yet and then we applied a bunch of
tricks so for example this pop contract
of kontrick popcorn
okay so he put all of that together then
what you end up with is something like
this so this green dots they correspond
roughly to this plot that I showed you
earlier this one over to Yvonne and then
the red one is it's our workout which is
our high level algorithm that we built
around like the course saving routines
which makes use of some tricks that were
discovered earlier where you get some
dimensions for free and and as you can
see the crossover between in terms of
running time between enumeration and
serving is dimension 70 right then if
you look at kind of the time so like
instances that take ten seconds to run
that's where the crossover is the 0.2
one beta roughly an end time for those
instances the largest one was about 250
gigabytes 420 SVP sitting and dimension
hundred 20 yen 78 yeah I never
and it's Lee stupid but is that one core
yeah be comparing on one core yeah
because to make the comeback me
so Jessica paralyzes quite well on
multiple course we compare with single
core FeO so I'm pretty sure we were fair
and compared with a single core Jessica
it would be very surprising no I can
pretty sure yeah well enumeration
paralyzes quite well as well it's just
the the implementation we're comparing
with didn't not manage that is well
marked it but so there's Mark's pal
enumeration which saw good performance
yeah yes correct
in so we have an implementation of
parallel enumeration in FPL now we don't
have strategies that explored in FeO now
and those are really crucial
like what pre-processing to use in order
now that you have much fast enumeration
because you have many course because llo
still a signal call
yes yes so this is so this is not just
let's just blindly safe in dimension 70
but let's so essentially we sit in a
small dimension and extend it and we go
back down so we keep improving the basis
to make our serving No so this is a
single this is a single cause it's not
amortized times you can also what you
can do is you can see if in dimension 60
and then you can use the database of
dimension 60 to seven dimensions 61 and
this is what's happening here
okay then another point of comparison so
the biggest like the you know the
largest experiments that were done on
lats reduction would be in response to
the dumbster SVP challenges which really
are her mid SVP 1.05 challenges and so
the so this is these challenges posed by
people from tu Darmstadt asks you to
find vectors that are not more than a
factor of 1.05 larger than the ego
heuristic for increasing lattice
dimensions and the blue and the red dots
they correspond to entries from the hall
of fame right so we like to have a
website where you can you know a Hall of
Fame and then we kind of they describe
how long it took them to compute this
and so we we try to kind of turn those
into CPU cycles somehow and then produce
these kind of blue dots the the red dots
a dotted line that's the one over to e
line that I showed you earlier so this
is how long it would take to solve SVP
exactly the green line is my simulation
when you relax the condition like you're
fine with 1.05 so we can see it's a
slightly easier problem and you might
argue back the green line and the blue
and the red dots they're kind of a line
I want to stress this is just a
simulation right and it's a single-core
simulation assuming everything parallels
perfectly so these guys achieving that
line is is it is an achievement right so
this is not to say look we expected that
kind of from the simulations it is
actually quite something that they
managed to get this and also up to
dimension I think 149 was the the
previous one before we did our work
something in that ballpark but anyway
the key takeaway is the green dots right
because that's us
and so and more importantly that's
sitting right so this is Jessica and as
you can see it's significantly faster
there would be another dot now which I
don't actually know kind of red lines on
there cycles because the difficult
so lay your vessel mark that they did
something like Jessica on GPUs and I
think that's 157 now okay so so as far
as the largest experiments that we know
are concerned saving now kind of
consistently outperforms enumeration in
practice okay try it at home kits all of
this is publicly available and then I
think that is something worth stressing
so like the code that we use to produce
those computations is available on
github so feel free to use it improve it
play with it okay
a big open question in that kind of area
of research would be what how does how
do things paralyzed in non-uniform
memory access settings right so you were
paralyzed across many different machines
and you have bandwidth considerations so
far all we've done is one big machine
one big blob of RAM and you can access
it then of course we didn't implement
the asymptotic key fastest sips so the
question is can it how fast can we make
those in practice and then well we
already mentioned GPUs but then of
course what you want is probably
combined some FPGA for your pub counts
maybe with GPUs or you know whatever
hardware you want to build for your
serving okay so that was serving versus
enumeration the other divergence in that
table that I gave at the very beginning
is the difference between classical and
quantum estimates so both classes of
algorithms we have algorithms that
quantum improvements to them so in in
the Seven case while we are looking in a
database or vectors to find some letter
short we can formulate this as a grover
search and enumeration is an exhaustive
search so you can indeed again use
something along the lines of our grover
search to speed that up and as you will
see so the
the estimate right so these are both of
these quantum lines really quite
optimistic estimates for the speed-up so
the in the quantum version of
enumeration the estimate is simply you
have everything right so we take the
square root because Grover because one
big search use compared with the search
that's the estimate for the cost of that
whereas for saving you get a get a small
reduction in the leading leading
coefficient all right so the like it's a
bit underwhelming right so you think
about like all Grover does here is it
doesn't divide by two
but it only reduces this slightly so let
me give you some impression of why that
seems to be the case for now the reason
is that Grover's really great an
unstructured search right that's what
what it does well but it gives you
squared for unstructured search the
search that we have in front of us is a
structured search we don't have to
actually do a black box search so to
illustrate this take a Gauss if write
the Gauss it would be essentially a sift
it doesn't exploit any of the structure
where you can bucket things and so on
and when you then said well I have my
database size of 0.2 1 and then I have
my square root for each of the searches
then you end up with a quantum cost of
0.3 1 1 and you end up with the same
memory as before but if you actually
start to make use of the structure of
your search space and consider the B
TJ's if we exact you achieve the same
complexity but classically no that's one
trial two gjc but you have to retry it
many times
ok polynomial factor for each each for
each bracketing you have exponentially
small probability TJ
35 or 36 is okay I stand corrected you
can get almost the same complexity okay
sorry about that
but notably you get the same memory so
that that bet I know okay
on the other hand when you compare those
two classes of algorithms right so what
you want to do is you want to maybe move
away from just the the abstract I just
put a square root on it but using Grover
but you want to have a more refined
understanding of what would actually
cost to implement these algorithms and
so in the serving context your major
operation is to compare two vectors Y to
see if they reduce to something we can
implement this using this XO on PubCon
trick so the circuit that we can that
the quantum circuit we need to implement
can be actually quite small so that's
good on the other hand we need a quantum
accessible RAM for our six because we
actually searching through this database
of vectors so we need QM and it's really
not clear that we can build efficient
qrm and the reason is you will need
error correction on your qrm and so you
need to do active computations on on all
your memory cells in order to maintain
them in their state so you don't get
this kind of cheap like let's just
abstract away Ram so that is a bad thing
about right so it's not even clear that
we can build very efficient Kirra
on the other hand enumeration the
circuit is likely going to be bigger
because you're probably not going to get
away with just a bunch of X's and then a
pop count so the circuit is going to be
bigger as I just mentioned but you don't
need exponential Kyurem so that's nice
and so just to give you an illustration
of how small you can make these quantum
circuits so this is our circuit for
quantum serving and all it does is a
bunch of X source and you have an adder
and then you
would carry right so it's this is a
really small circuit and then what you
can do is you can compare what you would
expect if you implement B DGL using this
circuit and then you apply the most
recent estimates for the cost of error
correction of circuits of this size that
are running for this period of time and
so on so this is from the recent RSA
factoring Shor's algorithm paper so they
give me and paper and so the - dotted or
whatever it's called line that would be
kind of the just take the leading
exponent then the next one up would be
the reading spawn of the classical
algorithm the green one is we estimate
the size of the circuit and so on in a
Ram model so classically and then the
blue one would be what if you actually
throw in like what we currently
understand to be the cost of error
correction right and so so that would be
our current understanding for the costs
for lower bounds for the cost of
implementing quantum saving the reason
I'm saying lower bounds is neither of
these take into account the
sub-exponential parts of the algorithm
because we assume those are classical
and they are the same in both so I could
shift everything up and we also only
look at the really the core routine
which is a nearest neighbor search right
so there's a there's a bunch of stuff
that we didn't cost here so these the
please do not take these as actual costs
of learning this but they give you you
would you would have to give them our
current understanding you have to run
this many operations in order to run bgl
on the quantum no because we are only
doing SVP so sorry it's sitting in
dimension D so and we also assume that
that mention fee will be the same in
both algorithms so for the comparison of
the two algorithms like classical and
quantum Li it makes no difference
so we
we need newest neighbor search in that
dimension wouldn't we
yeah I didn't know so we don't like it
so it has a from top of my head I don't
know because we use we don't use BT J
reduce bt j 1 which is only one level of
PG j i forgot what the leading constant
was of that we have written it down
somewhere any of my co-authors note from
the top of the head I can't answer this
in any meaningful way ok so I think it
would be nice if someone could write
down a quantum circuit for enumeration
so we have a better understanding my gut
feeling is it's going to be kind of
drive up this cost you know they keep
this you know the spare wood thing that
people use like you would have to add a
massive constant to that because the
circuit should be relatively large and
then of course like but this is really
not a very useful open problem but it
would be nice if you know maybe we
shouldn't design our algorithms let's
take the best classical algorithm and
slap Grover on it but let's think more
carefully about kind of like how to
design quantum algorithms last thing or
second to last thing I want to do is so
I want to stress that almost all entries
in this table are lower bounds of some
sort under some assumptions right
assuming this class of algorithms you
probably can't do better than this
and that's fine if you want to pick
parameters for your crypto scheme it's
great like it gives you it gives you
some confidence in like yeah maybe you
can't do better but what this does is
ignores polynomial factors and maybe can
be quite substantial they ignore for
example the max depth of your quantum
computation right so how long you can
run it the cost of a Grover iteration
cost of memory access and so on and
that's the we have to be really careful
about how we discuss those
abouts so for example if somebody finds
a new lower bound something for a class
a family of algorithms right so say I
tell you 1 over 8 is not the lower
button enumeration can do better than 1
of 8 you know i pathetically then this
does not necessarily imply if it's just
in you lower bounds that people should
adjust their parameters right because it
doesn't necessarily mean that there's an
algorithm corresponding to it all right
so just because you have lower bounds
does mean if algorithms that correspond
to it we also need to be a bit careful
about what conclusions we draw from this
so for example there will be some
classes of algorithms that really make
no sense whatsoever in these kind of
estimates where you just take the
leading constant times beta so you will
never win by making any guesses for
example there will always be worse but
if you actually take the real cost of
running serving into account
maybe guessing a little bit actually
improves things right so you want to be
careful about ruling out classes of
algorithms simply by using these lower
bounds because you might prevent
progress by like oh actually I can do
something here I can have some
improvement I can apply some new tricks
and and this is my last slide it's just
like I didn't talk about all the
algorithms so there's also be kW which
is combinatorial techniques can be quite
efficient for small secrets you can use
Grabner basis asymptotically efficient
but the AK the constants in the exponent
are massive so we're looking not at all
point three we're looking at something
six or if not larger so it I have not
seen any set of parameters that you
would actually consider where this is an
actual thing you need to consider
there's a hybrid attack which combines
combinatorial techniques without
reduction the rule of thumb pay is if
your secret is unusually small or sparse
then probably these are not the
algorithms I need to worry about
so if it's short and sparse maybe take
these algorithms to cut into account if
it isn't then lattice reduction should
be the most efficient one it's a rule of
thumb but I guess someone wrote a script
for that okay thank you
[Applause]
I have even run an experiment yeah my my
guess is it doesn't make that much of a
difference but but that like what am i
basing this on nothing yeah
or there are other ways to do LSH for
saving the work well so you just said
basically takes a product
so that's how we kind of might this is
actually what we implemented there yeah
yeah so I think this LSH function is
optimal at least for the way we model
them because you model them as points on
a sphere and I think then this LSH
function is the best that we know
there are no more questions left I'm
just again
[Applause]